tu pars au travail non je vais rire
d'abord qui vient déjeuner avec nous non
je vais rire d'abord ces conversations
vous nous avez pas entendu c'est normal
elle n'existe pas par contre je fais le
pari que dans peu de temps on va les
intégrer dans notre quotidien
j'en suis convaincu parce qu'aujourd'hui
la chance les neurosciences la médecine
également affirme que le rire est une
pratique utile indispensable voire vital
à notre fonctionnement naturel
c'est-à-dire notre physiologie mais
aussi notre mental et en plus
indispensable dans nos relations avec
les autres
je vais vous parler d'un rire pas le
rire des histoires drôles des films
comiques qui sont des rires qui sont
très bien on les garde
mais c'est un concept un peu différent
il ne sera pas sujet de ce marais de se
poiler de faire les petits fous d'être
qu'un rigolo de faire le rigolo c'est
bien plus que ça donc je suis fabrice
oiseaux beaux soirs depuis plus de vingt
ans je me suis demandé comment mettre
plus de positif voire plus de bonheur
dans mon quotidien dans mes idées dans
mes pensées
dans mes réflexions dans mes actes avec
mes amis et que ma famille au travail
également
et je dirige l'institut aujourd'hui
français international du yoga du rire
ça existe avec un médecin qui l'a fondé
cette méthode est ensemble un autre
boule vous j'ai du mal à dire boulot
notre mission je vais dire un cdu
diffusé du rire en france et à
l'étranger
par contre ce n'est pas un rire comme je
voulais d'histoires drôles
je vais commencer par des petites choses
que vous savez tout ça on a tous fait
l'expérience du rire on l'a en commun
quand on réfléchit on s'aperçoit que
lorsque vous riez impossible de penser à
vos tracas vos soucis vos problèmes il
se crée naturellement un stop mental ça
l'air de rien mais je vais explorer un
petit peu avec vous ce que j'entends par
stoke mental les scientifiques nous
apprennent que nous avons un petit vélo
là haut qui nous envoie une bombarde
uniquement de choses que nous n'aimons
pas c'est malin les scientifiques aiment
bien dénombré quantifier et on sait
combien de rumination 10 des parasites
autrement dit que nous avons par jour je
vous l'annoncé de 30000 à 65000
bombardement et ces bombardements ne
portent uniquement sur ce que nous
n'aimons pas sur ce que vous n'aimez pas
vos cravo doute vos peurs jamais sur le
dernier plaisir jamais sur les rires que
vous avez pu entendre tout à l'heure
lors de la vidéo ça c'est oublier donc
le rire apporte déjà un truc très
important c'est le stop mental et puis
quand moore également qui est impossible
de le faire quand le corps est tendu
crispé
naturellement le corps va évacuer les
tensions
là j'ai simplement de vous dire de façon
très simple lorsque vous riez vous
apporter du bien-être à votre mental à
votre corps pour appelle ça une
relaxation global mieux encore avec le
yoga du rire ça apporte beaucoup plus et
on va voir ensemble
j'ai même envie de vous proposer tout de
suite un premier exercice d'échauffement
je vais vous demander de vous mettre
debout
merci lui
voilà premiers exercices d'échauffement
on va préparer le corps à bien recevoir
obtenir un reer telle que nous
l'entendons qu'ils soient effectivement
bon pour le mental pour le corps et pour
le coeur également à les inspirations
ensemble vous êtes prêt avec vous mais
on va l'élever inspiration expiration
avec le son à inspiration excellent
inspiration très très bien maintenant on
va faire un comme un ballon de baudruche
qui se dégonfle e rey pour l'instant on
va gonfler et après on va se dégonfler
vous suivez c'est tout simplement ce que
je vais faire inspiration je suis gonflé
à bloc expiration je me dégonfle comme
un ballon et je relâche un hockey et une
deuxième fois inspiration je suis gonflé
à bloc expire le ballon qui se dégonfle
parfait autre exercice de préparation je
vous demande sortir enfin de les avoir
devant vous on va faire des mouvements
avec des sons les sons cdo aider à ces
partis ensemble qu on recommence haut et
on y va
trop haut
a ok super vous êtes prêts on va faire
le test maintenant je vous propose de
vous tourner vers vos voisins voisines
voilà
prendre le temps
vous m en face voilà quand il vend et et
je vous propose un scénario du futur
comment se dire bonjour dans le futur un
bon jour qui soit vraiment accueillants
et joyeux propose de serrer la main de
la personne qui est à côté de vous de la
regarder
et plutôt que de parler à la place on va
y mettre un reer ne le sur jouez pas les
hits tout simplement
[Rires]
ah ah
ça lui les personnes devant derrière sur
les côtés salué tout le monde chaque
année
rifle aaa aaa aaa aaa
ah ah
excellent ça c'est du bon jour allez
petit exercice trop au hockey ali
deuxième exercice très simple préparez
vous vous êtes super et je le montre
aller
ça s'appelle le shaker pour faire le
geste et au lieu de boire puisque nous
en aurions gars du rire on va y mettre
un rire ces partis ensemble et
hahahahahahaha deuxième fois
ah ah super
si j'avais pris une photo serait peut
être quelqu'un d'entre vous il ya comme
un avant et un après là je vais revenir
un tout petit peu sérieux et en même
temps dans sérieux au coeur vous allez
remarquer ce qu'il y a au coeur de
dubeau sérieux yari alors d'un côté vous
avez peut-être avant comme vous étiez
tout à l'heure et après après avoir fait
deux trois exercices vais te retrouver
peut-être ici si j'ouvre le chapitre
médicale voilà ce que j'aurais à vous
dire la personne qui rit va avoir une
meilleure résistance aux maladies
son système immunitaire va être boostée
et on va même être protégés des petits
maux divers notamment tous et rhume mais
pas que ça on sait que vous aurez une
digestion plus facile et moins de
constipation ça peut intéresser du monde
vous aurez moins de cholestérol vous
aurez un sommeil davantage profond et
récupérateur si vous avez des soucis de
diabète d'hypertension le rire va vous
aider donc autrement dit je vous fais
pas tout la liste mais il ya de vrais
avantages d'un point de vue médical
je vais ouvrir maintenant un autre
tiroir c'est le tiroir des émotions vous
le savez mais je vais je vais quand même
vous le dire le rire détruit point par
point ce que le stress a mis en place la
preuve en est on à une étude qui montre
que 15 minutes de rire en continu avec
le yoga du rire mais plus de marqueurs
de stress dans votre sens et au
contraire vienne apparaître les fameuses
hormones du bonheur
les fameuses endorphines et dopamine et
nora les rallyes mais aussi docile bref
et vous avez bien entendu le phénomène
est naturelle je ne vais pas chercher un
outil me connecter à un objet tout
simplement dans notre corps 15 minutes
de rire en continu va vous apporter
justement tous les éléments pour changer
votre humeur pour être plus dynamique
avoir plus d'optimisme et ça ça
fonctionne pour tout le monde puisque
c'est quelque chose d'universel on est
conçu comme ça c'est une des grandes
découvertes des neurosciences je dirais
puisque en orient c'est ça depuis des
millénaires
en ligue 1 on sait ça depuis très très
longtemps
alors on a des avantages sentais très
bien on est j'en dirais on a un visage
qui exprime la bonne humeur et bill va
découler un troisième avantage et qui
éprouvait en plus c'est que vous
améliorez votre confiance en vous vous
trouvez votre ouverture aux autres et
votre empathie
quelque part ça vous rend beaucoup plus
sympathique dans vos relations avec les
autres
votre relationnel est carrément amélioré
alors tous ces petits avantages sur la
santé sur les émotions
d'ailleurs les émotions je pourrais
ouvrir un jeu pourrait être plus long ce
chapitre les scientifiques manar savent
ce qu'il nous faut pour que l'on passe
une bonne journée on avait des modèles
très complexe autrefois effectivement
qui était très très très construit très
universitaire maintenant vient découvrir
qu'il suffit de changer votre humeur
pour que votre journée soit mieux
apprécier et on va jouer sur l'humeur le
rire vague en moins de 15 minutes à vous
faire cette promesse de changer votre
humeur même s'il n'avait pas envie de
rire
donc je vous passez juste une petite
image sympa meilleurs produits de beauté
le rire et c'est naturel ok j'ai compris
il ya un avantage santé notre émotion
enfin notre gestion émotionnelle va être
améliorée et le contact avec les autres
sera encore meilleure j'ai envie de vous
dire que ça fonctionne dans toutes les
situations même dans des contextes où on
aurait pu croire que le rire n'a pas
trop sa place exemple l'entreprise
depuis qu'en 2007 une étude américaine a
montré que quinze jours de yoga du rire
à changer tous les paramètres de
l'entreprise on a vu une très haute
une nette hausse une forte augmentation
de la productivité est un critère super
important pour les employeurs
l'attachement à l'entreprise là qu ils
ont une équipe de groupe bref tous les
paramètres se sont améliorées et j'ai
même envie de vous dire que le gars du
rire à ses effets dans d'autres
contextes encore une fois incongru j'ai
une expérience de globe trotter du rire
du rire et j'ai été amené à faire du
gazier dans des pays ou dans des
situations a priori sembler compliqué
par exemple je suis intervenue en milieu
carcéral dans un endroit du monde séparé
par les deux continents américains où la
mer est là un passage de drogue de
trafic d'armes de traite pas de grand
banditisme et la première fois je suis
intervenu auprès de ces prisonniers en
milieu carcéral
donc j'avais affaire à des caïds quand
même là des gens qui souffrent qui se
font prendre pour des meurtres de sang
quand même c'est pas c'est leur logique
c'est leur pensée il se comprend des
éléments en prison donc j'interviens
auprès d'eux il n'a pas fallu dix
minutes pour même les caïds soit pris
par un fou rire et digne d'après ils se
sont retrouvés comme dans une cour de
récréation a joué comme des enfants
hélas ce n'est pas parce que c'est moi
qui anime et c'est tout simplement la
force de ce yoga du rire là il va
toucher quelque chose d'universel et
d'essentiel
après j'aurai d'autres d'autres
expériences notamment en milieu scolaire
en inde j'interviens enfin je suis
intervenu dans des programmes scolaires
notamment en primaire ou de papa depuis
mais en tous les cas la fois que j'y
suis retourné ses programmes officiels
donc l'équivalent de l'éducation
nationale il propose du rire parce
qu'ils se sont aperçus des effets que ça
apporte chez les scolaires et on a aussi
des études sur les étudiants au monde
qu'il ya une meilleure créativité
on montre aussi qu'ils ont une meilleure
capacité à accepter la charge de travail
bon
donc si on vous dit les programmes sont
chargés vous l'accueillez avec un rire
vous allez pouvoir vivre ça très
confortablement
alors avant de faire deux trois
pratiques j'ai envie de vous partager
deux trois secrets en tous les cas deux
piliers de fondement scientifique sur le
yoga du rire
le premier d'entre eux sets suivants il
est très simple fait comme si et on voit
un monsieur sur l'image qui se force à
rire et pour l'aider à se forcer à rire
ou plus loin d'avoir le rictus
on a mis des petites épingles parce que
par derrière il ya une vraie validation
scientifique
la première date de guillaume duchesne à
un docteur en médecine je crois qu'il
est français ou suisses 1865 1895 qui
avait montré que quand les gens faisait
ça même temps aucune joie
il se sentait mieux et en 1988 on a fait
une autre étude avec le fameux stylo
dans la bouche donc s'est aperçu que des
étudiants un grand nombre d'étudiants
dans la même salle on leur avait demandé
de porter un stylo dans la bouche de
façon horizontale qui se retrouver comme
ça
l'autre moitié des participants de ce
même groupe devait aussi tenir un stylo
dans la bouche mais pas de la même façon
il devait le tenir comme ça on n'aurait
pas expliquer de quoi il s'agissait
ils ont accepté la situation pendant
tout le temps du de la projection qu'on
leur a proposées et à la fin en revanche
questionnaire études et on s'aperçoit
bizarrement que ceux qui avaient le
stylo comme ça où beaucoup mieux
apprécier ce qu'ils ont vu que les
autres et en creusant un petit peu le
truc on s'aperçoit que avec l'irm qui
est arrivé on peut mieux comprendre le
fonctionnement a effectivement j'ai un
micro qui a trop ri je crois
ah on recommence
alors qu'est ce que je disais et des
mois vous suivez donc maintenant que
nous avons l'irm on sait mieux ce qui se
passe dans notre tête et on s'aperçoit
que lorsque vous faites ça même de façon
à stimuler simplement le rictus la
mécanique du geste vous activez votre
cortex préfrontal gauche ça sert à quoi
cette histoire tout simplement le cortex
préfrontal gauche c'est le centre de
gestion de vos émotions positives et
selon la plasticité neuronale et du
cerveau plus vous le faites plus ça
fonctionne il paraît même qu à un
dépressif un tout petit cortex
préfrontal gauche et nous simplement
riant
même si vous n'en aviez pas envie ça
marche ça c'était le premier truc que je
souhaitais vous dire on re découvre la
puissance ou plutôt le cadeau que nous
avons déjà en nous l'autre chose que je
voulais vous partagez motion kraits
e-motion les mouvements du corps ne sont
pas neutres qu'ils ont un impact sur
nous je remets le truc hein
[Rires]
donc c'est pour vous dire qu'il ya un
monsieur qui s'appelle william james
il est considéré comme le père de la
psychologie américaine et sa thèse a été
très provocante à l'époque pour un
occidental en tous les cas si voilà ce
qu'il avait dit ce sont les mouvements
et la posture de votre corps qui vont
impacter vos émotions votre mental il a
dit très clairement de par ses études
que lorsque si je ne suis pas timide et
que je me mets moi même je vais mon
corps dans une posture caricature elle
joue la corde et de timmy c'est à dire
vous voyez je croise une fois j'ai un
petit peu en arrière vous voilà je suis
un petit peu en retrait directement et
bien même si je ne suis pas timide mon
mental va être affectée par ma posture
et en vieux gars du rire lorsque nous
faisons ça par exemple tout à l'heure je
vous ai demandé de faire ça à vous
souvenez pas c'est pas neutre parce que
là en ce moment voici ce que le corps
fait comme expérience stable équilibré
poser aligner centrer et cetera mais en
plus ouverture grandeur et bien tous ces
petits messages corporels vont remonter
et changer la carte mentale avec ces
mêmes attributs autant vous dire que les
neurosciences viennent de redécouvrir
tout simplement la puissance du corps
c'est pour ça qu'en yoga du rire en fait
c'est tuer une juste combinaison de
mouvements de respiration et de rire et
que à ce régime là on va sécréter toutes
les bonnes endorphines et les bonnes
choses
alors nous allons faire deux trois
pratiques qui vous demander de vous
mettre debout
et peut-être déjà d'inviter un sourire
sur votre visage puisqu'on a eu deux
sets est pas neutre
alors chaque fois que l'on rit ce n'est
jamais pour se moquer à ambri avec n'est
jamais contre ni de quelqu'un évidemment
alors un exercice on a fait celui ci
tout à l'heure je vous propose est
maintenant de mettre votre main d'un
côté la deuxième main va rejoindre la
première est là on va étirer un rire ça
ressemble à ça et on commence à les
tirer aux et là on y arrive à aa
de l'autre côté et une nouvelle fois ça
c'est facile et au aaa vous êtes prêt à
ok vous allez prendre vos mains il est
positionné devant vous donc il n'y a pas
d'espacés entre nos mains tout de suite
et nous allons faire un reer
proportionnelle à l'espace à l'écart
entre nos mains donc pas des spas spas
de rire tout petit espace tout petit
rire
[Musique]
ah ah
aaa aaa aaa aaa aaa aaa testons voir si
ça marche dans l'autre sens
haha
aa à aa
là
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ok parfait
grande inspiration
je retiens je bloque et quand j'explique
c'est uniquement pourrir une nouvelle
fois je retiens je bloque à aa
près très près oh oh oh ah ah ok cette
fois-ci plaît aux eaux dans nos mains
l'oea a dans les mains de quelqu'un
d'autre et on change si on peu de
partenaires au bo à aa
hahaha photo aa à aa
ok parfait et alors je voulais pas dit
qu'il y avait un challenge la normale ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on fasse
plus grands éclats de rire du tedx vous
êtes ok alors on va le faire
proportionnelle on va lever
progressivement les mains et quand on
sera en haut ça sera pour faire une
explosion de rires donc on commence la
nôtre rire tout doucement
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excellent voilà j'étais juste venu vous
dire que ça existe et que même si dans
de ma génération dans cette société on
véhicule encore deux trois petites
choses du genre sur itunes et carys
gaulle aux tueries tu n'es donc pas
sérieux on a vu la démonstration ce soir
précédemment et aussi avec le recours
aux neurosciences que c'est dans cette
même société elles progressent elles
avancent et on vient de découvrir que le
rire c'est une fonction super importante
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]